>> THANK YOU, VERY MUCH.
IT IS BEYOND DISTURBING.
ONE OF THE GREEN RESERVIST IS
JOINING ME.
I FIRST HEARD ABOUT THIS, I
THOUGHT TO MYSELF THIS IS WHEN
I'M GLAD MY MOTHER AND FATHER
HAVE GONE TO THEIR FINAL RESTIN
PLACE BECAUSE I DON'T EVEN KNOW
HOW THEY WOULD REACT TO THIS.
THEY WOULD SAY WHAT HAS HAPPENE
TO OUR COUNTRY THAT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS COULD HAPPEN TO TWO
MARINES JUST TRYING TO GO AND
SEE THE SIGHTS IN THE CITY OF
BROTHERLY LOVE.
TAKE US THROUGH WHAT HAPPENED
THAT DAY.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
LAURA.
ME AND THE OTHER CORPORATION
OVER IN DOWNTOWN PHILLY IN THE
AREA AROUND THERE.
WE'VE NEVER BEEN IN THAT AREA
OURSELVES.
THAT WAS HER FIRST TIME.
WE WERE WITH OUR ENTIRE SQUADRO
TO MEET AT THE LIBERTY BELL BY
NOON SO NOT ONLY WERE WE THERE,
WE WERE MANDATED TO BE THERE BY
OUR COMMAND TO BE THERE FOR
PROFESSIONAL MILITARY EDUCATION
WHAT WE CALL, PME JUST TO CHECK
OUT THE LANDMARKS, CHECK OUT TH
HISTORICAL EXHIBITS AND REGULAR
CIVILIAN ATTIRE.
LO AND BEHOLD, WE NEVER KNEW
LATER ON WE WOULD FALL VICTIMS
TO THESE ACTIVISTS, WE WERE
THERE AT NOON AND MY FIRST
PRIORITY WAS SIMPLY TO GRAB A
BITE TO EAT, SO WE TOGETHER GO
FIND SOMEWHERE THAT THE CASUAL
RESTAURANT.
WE GET SOMETHING TO EAT AND HAV
PLENTY OF TIME THAT EVENING AT
OUR HEALTH AND WE HAD CORPORAL
AT THE HILTON HOTEL, SO TO
CELEBRATE THE 243rd BIRTHDAY
OF THE MARINE CORPS.
THAT WAS OUR PLAN.
>> WHEN DID YOU GET CONFRONTED
BY THESE CHARACTERS?
>> TAKE US TO THAT MOMENT.
WHAT HAPPENED?
ARE YOU DRESSED IN YOUR FULL
MARINE UNIFORM?
>> AT THE NOT AT ALL.
WE WERE THERE AT AND 12 IN
CIVILIAN ATTIRE.
UP UNTIL 3:00 P.M.
>> I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOU.
BUT YOU GET CLOSER.
WE SAW THE REPORTS, YOU'RE PROUD
, YOU'RE A MARINE.
AT THE FAR RIGHT GROUP THAT HAS
THESE LITTLE RALLIES.
HOW DID IT FEEL TO BE CALLED A
LOW WHITE SUPREMACIST FOR
SOMEONE OF HISPANIC DESCENT?
>> THAT IS EXTREME IRONY TO US.
WE FOUND IT VERY IRONIC AND
CONFUSING AS WELL.
I DON'T KNOW WHO WOULD LOOK AT
US AND WHAT SUPPORTERS WHITE
SUPREMACY OR NEO-NAZI OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
HE IS MEXICAN, I AM PUERTO RICAN
.
WE ARE TO HISPANIC MARINES ON
DUTY AND TO BE CONFRONTED BY NO
SUPPOSING THAT THERE IS ANYTHIN
RACIALLY CHARGED TOWARDS US
UNTIL THEY ASK US ARE WE PROUD
AND LATER ON THE CROWD JUST
CALLS US THESE RACIAL SLURS AND
THEN LATER ON CALLS US RACIAL
SLURS FOR BEING OF HISPANIC
HERITAGE, THE IRON HE WAS JUST
COLOSSAL.
>> SEMPER FI, MY FRIEND, MERRY
CHRISTMAS.
SORRY HAD TO GO THROUGH THIS.
I KNOW HE STILL SUFFERING THE
RESULTS OF THESE INJURIES.
YOU GUYS, THIS IS THE UNITED